Okay, so homework 1--what I'd like you to do is make a web page with a form on it
that let's you ROT 13 some text.
First, I'll explain what ROT 13 is.
Okay, so ROT 13 is a simple cipher to run a simple encryption algorithm on some text.
So it looks something like this.
Okay, if I were to take this string 'Hello' and apply ROT 13 to it,
it would look like this--Uryyb.
What I've done is I've incremented every letter by 13.
So H becomes U. E becomes r. L becomes y. L becomes y, and o becomes b.
So if I had an alphabet like so--
if I were to convert each letter, I increment them by 13.
So 'a' moves 13 spaces and becomes 'n' or 'h' moves 13 spaces and becomes 'u'.
'z' wraps around moving 13 spaces and becomes 'm'.
So is you were to apply a Caesar cipher to itself,
you get the string you originally typed in.
It's not the fanciest cipher in the world, but I'm not trying to test your cryptography skills.
There's another class for that.
I'm just trying to test your web handling skills.
Let me show you what this should look like when it's all working.
Okay, so here's the app running on my appspot account at /unit2/ROT13.
If I type some text in this field and click submit,
it rerenders this form with my text in the text box, and if I were to hit submit again,
it converts it back to 'Hello".
Okay, this is what I'd like you to build.
A couple things to notice--1 is that it preserved case, so the capital H became a capital U
and the lowercase 'ello' became the lowercase 'ryyb'.
I'd also like you to preserve punctuation.
So I've expanded my text here to have an exclamation mark and a question mark.
When I ROT 13 this, it preserves the exclamation mark and the question mark,
and everything else becomes ROT 13.
You know it's working because when you run it again,
you get the original text.
I'd also like you to preserve whitespace, okay?
I've added some whitespace and another exclamation mark and everything worked.
And, here's one thing to look out for.
Remember you might need to escape some HTML.
Now this box here--this box for the text is using an element we haven't talked about.
It's called a text area, and it's another form element for entering large pieces of text.
If I were to include this in my text field and not escape it properly,
we could have problems.
But as you can see, I have escaped my less thans and greater thans properly,
so everything works.
I can go back to text area, and all is well.
Now this is running online, so you can verify what my expectations are
by playing around with my own version at this URL.
You can also if you want view the source of this page to see the HTML I was using
to draw the bigger box and that sort of thing.
It's fine if you want to use that.
What I want you to do is implement the backend part, and once you have it working,
I'd like you to enter the full URL where it's running here.
Now when we grade this, it's a little challenging.
Obviously, we're not going to be able to grade how it looks.
We're going to have an automated script that submits some data and looks at the response.
Make sure you follow the notes below to have the correct input name,
so when I submit directly to your form, I can find my text in the result.
Okay, good luck!